Woah...
Thunderdome.
It’s been a pretty intense
six weeks since we started this.
We were nervous but,
we’re okay now.
Yeah, we went to a bar
next to here
to have a beer,
and now we are super chill.
Just one beer – don’t worry.
Also the storm made everything
that much more intense.
What we’re going to do is regress
according to our schedule,
for thirty minutes per team
to present and ask questions
from our jurors.
It’s really intimidating.
The camera is more intimidating
than the jurors.
Well, you’re going to get
both of us at the same time.
Hi, I’m Frida.
Nice to meet you.
Thanks for coming out.
This is 2 meters.
And this is, again, something
that we can play with.
-2 meters deep?
-Yeah.
That’s quite the slide.
So it’s almost as tall as a wall.
I am interested in this tension
between art and architecture.
And this obviously pushes that
very hard.
There is something really
universal about this shape
and the slope,
and it can relate to these other
very universal images –
a staircase, for example,
you know the plaza,
with the staircase?
-Okay.
-Thank you.
-Thank you so much.
Over the years, we’re witnessing
changes in ideas
about what makes architecture.
And this year is,
without a doubt,
one of the most diverse
in terms of responses.
I don’t think we’re looking
to program exact activities,
but we’re trying
to leave it open
for different kinds of behaviors
to take place.
I’m struck by the association of
two seemingly antithetical ideas –
one is the artist’s residence,
which is about being alone,
and the other is Warm-Up,
which is about being together.
-Those were good questions.
-Yeah.
They were really,
really good questions.
Are there new materials at all,
that you looked at?
Whether they’re synthetics
or something else
super lightweight...
We considered trying to do
something as fabric,
or the kind of metal netting
that you see.
Does the budget include
the de-install also?
Yeah.
So we thought,
let’s establish a system.
Let’s work with the walls,
with their existence,
to generate new atmospheres
on each face of the courtyard.
How are you going to get the rope
through that thickness and pull it out?
We plan to use an 8mm rope.
And the mist is coming
from the water?
-Here’s the mist.
-Ah!
-Thank you.
-Thank you so much.
We started
with a mutual interest
in looking at some
Druid-style monuments.
These are dolmens,
and it really looks like something
has landed into this courtyard.
Why is a dolmen
an appropriate element
for 2016 in New York City?
Thank you.